[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la capitale fédérale ne sera plus jamais
la même
Ottawa occupé
paralysé et secouer
[Musique]
aujourd'hui des camions ont disparu mais
la ville porte toujours les traces du
convoi de la liberté
la rue Wellington devant le Parlement
désormais fermé à la circulation en il
symbole le plus frappant les souvenirs
du convoi sont encore vives dans
l'esprit du conseiller municipal Mathieu
Fleury
à l'époque là
résonne ces bâtiments l'odeur
[Musique]
commerce fermé citoyen harcelé l'élu qui
est père de famille à lui-même été
menacé après avoir suggéré de couper les
sources de financement aux manifestants
on a tous eu des menaces par courriel
par appel par courrier puis moi j'ai eu
des menaces des visites chez nous qui
nous ont forcés à déménager
Ottawa se prépare à replonger dans les
déchirements de cet épisode sans
précédent pendant 6 semaines une
commission d'enquête tentera de
déterminer s'il l'utilisation des
mesures d'urgence par le gouvernement
Trudeau pour mettre fin à la
contestation était justifié le Premier
ministre des ministres des policiers et
des organisateurs du convoi devraient
donner leur version des faits
début 2022 l'obligation vaccinale pour
les camionneurs cristallisent
l'opposition au restrictions sanitaire
le gouvernement fédéral est confronté à
une manifestation monstre dans la
capitale fédérale et des blocages à des
postes frontaliers
le 12 février les policiers et des
places de force les manifestants qui
bloquent le pont ambassadeur entre
Windsor et D3 deux jours plus tard le
gouvernement Trudeau prend les grands
moyens le gouvernement fédéral invoque
la Loi sur les mesures d'urgence la Loi
sur les mesures d'urgence et décrétées
pour la première fois depuis son
adoption en 1988
Ottawa pu ainsi limiter les mouvements
réquisitionner des remorqueuses et je
les dés avoir encore aujourd'hui Justin
Trudeau défend l'utilisation de ses
pouvoirs spéciaux on a
utilisé des mesures qui étaient
proportionnelles et nécessaire le
recours à la Loi sur les mesures
d'urgence était injustifiées selon
l'Association canadienne des libertés
civiles qui contestent son utilisation
devant les tribunaux c'est sérieuse la
police a réussi à mettre fin au barrage
de Windsor et de coûte son Alberta sans
les pouvoirs spéciaux le critère d'une
urgence nationale n'a pas été établie
selon l'association que cette menace
soit suffisamment grave
pour mettre en mesure pour pour menacer
la sécurité des Canadiens la sécurité de
l'État et d'après l'association c'est
seuil n'a pas été franchi justifié ou
pas la commission d'enquête doit tenter
de répondre à cette question dans un
rapport en février les conclusions
pourraient bien éclabousser le
gouvernement les présente aussi des
risques politiques pour le Parti
conservateur
le nouveau chef Pierre pollièvre et
certains députés avaient appuyé le
convoi
conservateur et bloquiste était opposé à
l'utilisation des pouvoirs d'urgence le
bloc dénonce le manque de transparence
du gouvernement Trudeau ministère de la
Sécurité publique des grandes pages
caviardées le comité parlementaire qui
se penche sur l'utilisation des pouvoirs
d'urgence n'a pas eu accès à toute
l'information justifiant ces mesures
extraordinaires donc finalement tout le
monde allait bien secret pour pas
répondre à nos questions il espère que
la commission d'enquête permettra d'y
voir plus clair c'est là où on a vu les
remorqueuses commencer à retirer aux
yeux de Mathieu Fleury des pouvoirs
spéciaux découlant de la Loi sur les
mesures d'urgence pour contribuer au
retour à la normalité chez lui en
premier lieu ça demeure une ville qui
doit être capable de vivre puis de
protéger ses résidents et ses
entreprises
entre le sort d'une ville assiégée une
gestion policière déficiente et
certaines libertés individuelles
suspendues la crise était complexe reste
que le gouvernement Trudeau devra tout
de même justifier l'utilisation des
mesures d'urgence et le précédent qui
l'a créé
Ottawa Daniel tout ça c'est très
politique est-ce que c'est risqué cet
exercice pour Justin Trudeau il y a
toujours des risques Louis l'évoquait
dans son reportage Céline bon Justin
Trudeau d'abord c'est la conclusion du
juge rouleau à la fin de l'enquête c'est
que le gouvernement n'avait pas les
justifications nécessaires pour invoquer
la Loi sur les mesures d'urgence ce sera
cité par ces opposants comme un autre
preuve de son manque de jugement un peu
comme les vacances sur l'île de la gacca
nous l'affaire SNCF d'un autre côté il y
a un risque aussi pour Pierre poirievre
qui a été on l'a vu dans les images
étroitement associé à ce qu'on voit là
il y a fort à parier que les témoins du
gouvernement vont souligner même si de
façon subtile cette association là pour
la rappeler au public peut-être pour la
cimenter dans la mémoire des électeurs
qui ne s'en souviendraient pas ceci dit
ce sont des risques qui sont limités ce
qui était d'accord avec le gouvernement
Trudeau vont demeurer d'accord ce qui
s'opposait à la Loi sur les mesures
d'urgence vont continuer proposer au
bout du compte ça demeure un exercice
hautement politique qui se tient d'abord
et avant tout faut-il le rappeler parce
que la loi l'impose les pierres
pollièvre a présenté d'ailleurs son
cabinet fantôme aujourd'hui par
communiquer il n'a pas parlé aujourd'hui
c'est un peu c'est un peu devenu la
marque de commerce de Monsieur pollièvre
depuis son accession à la tête du Parti
conservateur outre cet incident dans le
foyer de la Chambre des communes nous
prise de bec avec un journaliste il
l'avait forcé à répondre à deux
questions il n'a pas rencontré la presse
depuis qu'il est à la tête du Parti
conservateur peut rencontrer le
journaliste pas de grandes entrevues non
plus donc aujourd'hui ça s'est fait par
communiquer et des surprises dans ce
cabinet fantôme qu'est-ce que vous
retenez beaucoup de monde 51 postes de
porte-parole qui font face à 38
ministres du côté du gouvernement
Trudeau donc pas mal de monde il y a une
vingtaine de porte-parole à joints qui
s'ajoutent à ça à quelques nominations
intéressantes Dominique vient qui est
porte-parole adjointe femme égalité de
des gens et jeunesse l'ex-ministre pro
au Québec on aurait pu s'attendre à ce
qu'elle est un poste un peu plus
important Joël Godin qui durant la
course avait menacé de quitter le
participe à poignet avant le dirigeait
demeure porte-parole des langues
officielles Richard Martel qui a fait du
bon travail sur OK Canada demeure au
sport et développement économique du
Québec attardons-nous sur la dernière
Gérard Deltel qui est porte-parole
environnement changement climatique
nomination intéressante dans ce cas là
qu'est-ce qu'on doit y lire mais
peut-être que Monsieur Poirier voulait
un bon communicateur dans un dossier qui
est généralement épineux pour les
conservateurs monsieur Deltel pourrait
au surplus être appelé à contribuer à
l'élaboration de la prochaine plateforme
verte des conservateurs donc avoir un
influence ça pourrait aussi être un
couteau à double tranchant parce qu'il
pourrait devoir se retrouver sur le
terrain au Québec à défendre des idées
qui ne seraient peut-être pas tout à
fait populaire auprès de certaines
portions d'électorales oui alors à
suivre merci Daniel